is it safe to say that it's uh
people find it counterintuitive to know
that you're
like
at dispensaries selling weed and stuff
you know what i just i'm enjoying the
rebranding of what cannabis is to be
quite honest all right you know i didn't
grow up as a kid uh smoking or or any of
that stuff never even got in trouble
with the law um but uh but i was in my
early thirties man i went on a ski trip
with some buddies of mine at aspen and
they had some great [__]
and it was just like eye-opening how
great it was and then i started doing my
research and obviously purple uncle had
been around for many many years so
people have been sending me that little
snapshot you know like hey man you get
paid off this you get paid off rounds
like nope nope nope and i never even
thought to because it was just on the
other side of that fence right man our
new world is going to look so different
the cannabis industry is no different
than the wine industry man you know all
these trains are just varietals and for
the people who know what they're
shopping for you want to make sure they
get good stuff man that's really
interesting to compare the cannabis
industry to the wine industry
as opposed to
the alcohol industry in general
because
uh there's more connoisseurs in wine
like the same type of right i want
everything associated with what i did
um in the 90s and with tgif etc etc to
to live on in a positive way
and
i didn't create this this this is this
was the streets
saying this is how a section of us
ensure
so when you just lean into that and you
embrace that it's like it's like
embracing your own graffiti art you know
what i'm saying i'm like i'm sorry your
building got defaced
but you know damn it's a good mural you
know right right right before the before
i went and bought some some it's purple
yeah yeah yeah
i'm sober but i wanted to support it and
so i wanted to smell it you know yeah i
just want to smell it for the first time
on the
day i'm like why am i doing this
why do they do that dude like
it uh smells so good you can at least
you can at least let them know it smells
that good it smells so damn good well
i'm sorry
and then and i really regret smelling
that because it smells so damn good like
i'm like i'm a sober guy and i don't
like to be around
enough you know like
because it's too tempting yeah if people
are drinking alcohol around me that
doesn't really affect me but if people
are smoking weed i'm breathing it in oh
yeah but that's one reason why i'm not
even they told me that's why i was
smoking around
just just the whiff i i appreciate that
and i'd be the first person to tell you
steve no yeah that's evil steve no
but how do you pick what strain you want
for your
legacy so it's you know really it's
purple that's what the the actual name
of the company is um we just want to be
the best in purples so whether it's you
know old family purple's gdps you name
it um you know purple urkel was more or
less just of our our invitation to do
this um and we're just we're doing
crosses and whatever and up and up up in
our oakland facility and
um you know whatever comes out great we
we've done actual phenol hunts and uh
that was interesting it's a funeral hunt
is that like
like the spores right so that's where we
pop the seeds
and we get all these different plants
but we don't know what's special yet so
we just get rows and rows of plants and
then you go and you smell the plants
and like the first five plants i smelled
i turned to bread and i was just like
you know i don't think maybe i have the
nose talent for this maybe somebody else
who knows what they're doing he says no
keep going and then finally i smelled
something that smells smells uh smells
special
and um and he said okay cool and this
guy from behind us with a clipboard he's
like write that one down so we
what we do is we go through all the
after we pop all these seeds not all
these plants are going to be good we're
looking for something special
so we end up with maybe five or six
plants that are somewhat special if you
and that's a big volume but these guys
did a good job and and then that you
create a room off of that plant
oh and you're talking about seeds not
just so wouldn't you like top uh chop
off the top of the plant and then just
okay
no i don't know if i was about to chop
it off the top of it just actual seeds
well we popped these seeds and we and we
and we and we fill up a you know a large
portion of a room so that we
can find something special right and
once you find something special then you
proceed with with with that particular
plant and
that would be your mother plant and then
how long does that take you to from from
sniff to oh man that was today that was
like um
that was a four to six month process
right really yeah that really was cause
the first three months were just about
investigation and then the the back
three months are what the ones that you
chose
yeah dude thanks for watching that clip
and if you live in america there's a
good chance that this big badass tour
bus is coming to your town with my
bucket list tour what is it well it's an
x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]